hello everyone and welcome to the most
requested game from day one of the world
rapid championship it's linear Dominguez
versus on each gear it's again from
round five and it's a it's a long
theoretical struggle which which makes
this video even more interesting because
there are I think there are maybe a few
players who prepare for a chess game
better than any Giri he's just a master
of opening preparation that's why I
think you're really going to enjoy this
game so without further ado let's check
it out as day two is about to start so
we want to check at least this one
before we get to that so Dominguez with
the white pieces opens with E for I need
goes for the Sicilian defense we have c5
Knight f3 d6 and d4 so everything you
know standard stuff Knight f6 Knight to
c3 and the knight or variation is on the
board we have Bishop to e3 the so-called
English attack against the night off
with E 5 and the knight back to b3
Bishop to e6
and now f3 strengthening the center and
here our moves like Bishop e7 Knight bTW
seven are the most usual moves played
here but the Giri goes for h5 and Giri
is following the game Dominguez already
played against the team back row in 2014
which Dominguez one and it's gonna be
very exciting stuff when we get to the
turning point we have 90 d5 looming
there's a threatening Knight Bishop to
b6 followed by Knight to c7 check which
would win material so you have to react
to this Bishop captures each captors in
the now Knight bd7 now we have Queen d2
Dominguez prepares the castle at the
Castle queenside and g6 by theory yeah
we have castles Queen side Bishop to g7
and now you don't want your king and
queen on this same diagonal so King to
b1 just a much much better much more
safe square for the King we have Queen
the c7 just usual developing square for
the Queen the rook is coming to c8 we
had Bishop to e2 Dominguez prepares g4
and now that Giri castles we have g4 and
now rook F to c8 so still following the
game Dominguez the vs. back row from
2014 we have looked to see one you don't
want your
Queen stuck here guarding the c2 pond
and now h captures on g4 we have F
captors and g4 and now a five we have G
five and this is where we reach the we
were you the turning point in 2014 ATM
back row played and knights the e4 and
he lost that game but here Geary replies
with the strongest move recommended by
the engine which is a four so it is as a
move eighteen that we have a completely
new game so let's see how Domingues
faces this a four threat so he goes G
captors and f6 and of course it is the
best idea you don't have time to capture
the night because after C captures you
open up an attack on the Queen and also
you will just lose a piece here so first
Knight captures on f6 and this is where
it starts to get interesting here that
giri is down down a piece and well
doming us can just move back then i he
can go night to the a1 this is a one of
the strongest moves recommended by the
engine so probably this is what Geary
had planned for that Dominguez will try
and save the night and then the game
continues with the moves like Knight to
e4 or a3 yeah but it's blacks down a
piece but black is on the attack
however Dominguez after Knight captures
an f6 just continues the attack with h4
and he gives back the piece and okay
Geary accepts the piece we have C
capture son b3 opening up an attack
towards the Queen so Queen to d7 and now
rook F this rook C to F 1 avoiding the
rook trade and shifting the rooks over
to the Kings side now with nicely for
attacking the Queen Quinta a1 and now
Queen back to c7 with ideas of well
either Queen to c2 check you can also
bring the Queen to a5 if if the White
Queen moves but Bishop to d3 not
allowing this Queen to see to idea we
have night the c5 threatening the the
light square bishop but here at
Dominguez just captures it Bishop
captures Queen captures and now Queen to
efore and already a lot of tricks alert
in the position like h5 is coming maybe
even recapture Sun f7 is an idea
followed by a queen captors and g6 of
course a Giri is not interested in
finding out and both
them are very low on time here gear he
pushes f5 kicks back the Queen and here
Dominguez could go back with the Queen
but instead he sacrifices the rook we
read you the position from the thumbnail
he plays rook captures on f5 and this is
the critical point of the game feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
best defensive move for Geary
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations on not grabbing the rook
right away and for the few of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's a
counter sacrifice rook captures on a two
point being that if you capture well
then it's just a beautiful beautiful
line you get captures on f5 and now it
doesn't matter if you move the Queen or
you capture on f5 it's it's besides the
point
you should play queen c4 and the hope
for a queen trade here because if you
don't then you get rotate check King b1
and now II for you open up the bishops
diagonal and prevent Queen to h7 check
so Bishop captures and now of course you
will see it it's rook to a1 check you
sacrifice another rope King captures
Queen a3 check the pawn is pinned you
cannot capture a king has the move and
Queen B to his mate
so this is what happens if after real
captures you capture it however the best
for white is to go rook to f8 check yet
another counter sacrifice rook captures
basically you you don't want the G
captures on f5 to kick away the Queen
from a4 so black has this freeing efore
move you don't want the dragon to awaken
rook captures on f8 and only now King
captors and a2 and now the game
continues this is what the giver should
have none however give recaptured there
right away he thought okay we're gonna
kick away the Queen then we push efore
we we free the dragon but Queen captures
on f5 now you you you don't have all
that much time to waste here we have
looked a c7 adding a rook to help out
with the defense but now not Queen h7
but rather look to f1 preventing the
King from escaping after Queen to h7 now
this is the threat of checkmate
rush up to f8 and now Queen g6 check
here now we have a repetition for a few
moves King h8 Queen h5 check King to g8
and now Bishop to f5 is really strong
threatening Bishop e6
but you kinda have to calculate the
bishop five queen capture Sundy five
queen g6 check first to gain control of
e6 and both of them are very low on time
so here Queen g6 check again King h8 and
now rogue g1 threatening a queen h5
check rook to h7 and queen h7 mate so
there's only one good way for Gary to
prevent mate and that is to give up the
Queen which is what Gary does Queen
captures and g1 Queen captures and
Bishop to h6 now threatening to win back
the Queen with rook the c1 and here
Domingues blocks of Bishop to c4 and
it's it's it's a really good block
because if b5 works then this this
doesn't work but b5 is a very exciting
move so of course you cannot move if you
move then of course you can equalize the
problem is you have Queen to g6 you
threaten to capture the bishop after
Bishop moves to f4 you have Queen to f6
check King moves and now Queen captures
and d6 attacking the rook rook defends
rook again you're asking what you want
to do with the bishop if you move it
it's still mate
so queen that e-cigs check keep the h8
and now d6 you threaten the rook and now
after the rook moves d7 and now white
wins so this is if if captures you just
bring the Queen into the game and there
is nothing left to do here so
fortunately b5 doesn't work there is the
Bishop c4 move we have Queen to Bishop
c4 we have rook to g8 now attacking the
Queen and now Queen to b6 attacking the
rook rook to d7 and now Bishop to b5
pushing the rook further back we have
rook D to g7 now and finally a for a
free move with the King now we look to
g6 defending this pawn that's a well
better to defend this guy didn't this
guy we've pushed back to d3 attacking
the rook and now rook to f6 and only now
Queen captures on b7 we have Bishop to
g7 now Gary's plan is that the push key
for free the bishop and then create some
threats along the second rank against
the White King we have Queen to b4 now
so if the pawn is captured you can
capture with the Queen also maybe
threaten mate we looked at f4 first
pushing the Queen back Queen captures on
d6 now and now rook captures on h4
we have Quinta
seven preparing to start pushing the
past pawn but now rook h1 check King to
a2 and now II for now the bishop is free
and here a giri will try to create some
threats against the white king we have
Queen captures on e4 and the now rook to
h2 so how do you stop rook captures on
v2 well bishop the c2 and this is again
where things get really interesting
rook the c8 attacking the bishop twice
so again you can't really move it kink
the b1 defending it and this is as good
a chance as Geary is gonna get if he
doesn't capture now on cc2 he can just
resign there there's no more playing
this game oh I can just push the past
points and it's game over
so here Gary captures it ro captures
Queen captures rook captures and King
captures so it's a bishop against four
pawns but now it's a race and let's see
who's faster King g8 weave King D three
kink the f8 with a5 now Bishop to e5
preparing to create a blockade on a
seven we have came to c4 and now King
the e7 we have a six and a now of course
Bishop to b8 you cannot allow a seven
King the c5 we have Kings to d7 and came
to b6 and it was in this position animal
55 that unnies giri resigned the game
and a brilliant brilliant victory for
for linear Dominguez in round five of
the world rapid championship 2019
whatever black does next move a seven is
coming you give up the the bishop for
the pawn and then well you don't have
enough Kings to stop all the points so
it's it's fairly simple
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
that I would like to thank Oliver birch
Hartman getler Anna Skye Sony better
angstrom and Robert cared for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon for the next few days we are
continuing the coverage of the world
rapid M blitz championship so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day